1/2 is equivalent to 8/16.
3/4 is equivalent to 12/16.
And 7/8 is equal to 14/16.
For each of these fractions we
had to multiply the numerator in
the denominator, each by some number in
order to get our new numerator over 16.
So, what did I multiply
by two to get 16?
I know that two goes
into 16 eight times.
Well if I do anything to the denominator
I have to do the same thing to
the numerator in order for
it to be the same fraction.
And then I get 1 x 8 = 8,
and that's my numerator.
And for 3/4 I had to find
some number to multiply it
by the denominator, 4,
to get the new denominator, 16.
And I know that 4 goes into 16,
four times, and
I do the same thing to the numerator.
And then 3 x 4 gives me 12.
And for 7/8, I know that
eight goes into 16 two times.
Two over two.
7 x 2 me 14.
It's okayif this is not
coming to you right away.
We'll give you lots of practice,
so you can get more comfortable.